from the air caca van der Rohe in the
northern part of the Central African
Republic looks pretty peaceful but what
we're seeing is actually a refugee camp
housing around 30,000 people some of
them from the city itself half of those
in the camper children many have been
badly traumatized like Lucie blue shoe
she's 12
from a village about 90 kilometres away
Lucie was forced to flee when her home
was attacked by rebels
I have no family I live with other
people from my village a teacher from
the village tells us that her mother was
taken by the rebels Lucy hasn't heard
from her since everyone else and her
family is dead
stories like Lucy's are not uncommon one
morning they came to our village
they had really big guns and started
shooting at everything in sight they
even killed children I ran away with my
family and came to this camp after
school we accompanied our Kia back to
his new home in the refugee camp only
his grandfather is there to greet him
it's very hard to survive here there's
not much aid and we no longer have
fields to plant things to eat only God
can help us the camp went up a year ago
practically overnight after an armed
group attacked the Christian district of
the city seeking protection the people
there fled to UN troops stationed nearby
kaga bond arrow is a divided city the
small river that flows through its
geographic center serves as the border
the center in the northern districts is
in the hands of the Muslim rebel militia
called silicon the southern districts
are occupied by their largely Christian
opponents known as the anti-balaka many
houses are deserted here next to that
are the UN barracks the kaga Bandera
refugee camp grew up next to its
protective fence the blue helmets took
up positions on the city's only bridge
in an attempt to keep the two warring
sides apart but the raids continue there
are around 12,500 UN soldiers in the
country only a few residents have dared
to return to their homes Florentine Don
Betty lives in a hut built amidst the
wreckage of his former farm which was
destroyed by the Celica can't sleep here
anymore
a woman was robbed here yesterday
someone robbed her of 25 thousand francs
I spoke with the authorities about the
security situation here it's not safe in
this part of the city security donek de
Loup has worked for UNICEF in the
Central African Republic for years the
Kaka bandura camp is just one of many in
the country she says and things are
getting worse the humanitarian needs are
increasing sadly more and more people
are under attack our IDPs where now we
have 600,000 people who are internally
displaced within the country which is
what it was at the peak of the crisis in
2014 so there's still a lot to do among
the refugees tens of thousands of
children who were taken up by armed
groups the UN is trying to liberate as
many as possible from the Warlord's and
rebels but many struggle to reintegrate
into society many of the girls were kept
for years as sex slaves I was 12 and
lived in Bunge an armed group forced me
to go with them
since then I've lived around here I'm 17
now it was terrible
don't be like that I saw and did the
most awful things the life I had all
those years I was no life at all as I
say I used some villainy ain't gone
there's no safe haven for children in
this environment of violence at least
there's a playground in the camp but the
legacy of war is unmistakable even here
sometimes Akhil spends time with other
children in the camp in the afternoon
but nothing is like it used to be I had
a good life in my village I had lots of
friends we had a lot of fun together we
had school lessons under the big tree in
the evenings we sang and danced in the
moonlight but that's all gone many of my
friends are dead and the others are in
refugee camps
Lucia Nikhil share a similar fate and
they now face a highly uncertain future
and as it stands now a peaceful solution
between the warring parties seems
unlikely
you